those franchises are terrible the modern
incarnations of some of these franchises
that have been around more than 20 years
and aside from student debt let's
suppose someone
has been fortunate enough to have their
education entirely covered let's talk
about the over reliance on an alma mater
i went to this school therefore
i deserve a job yeah i'm not i don't
know uh the alma mater thing being part
of a club i don't know i i i always
but see i'm a person that i i'm i can
meet almost any stranger and find some
level of connection
you know we're both parents
you know we both love cats
we have a love of uh frank herbert
uh or uh you know like i can find some
connection i like
football
uh just because um
you know i like watching live sporting
events where there are stakes involved
you know um
but i don't take sports all that
seriously i do think that those club
connections that is one way to connect
but when it comes to people almost any
type of person i can find a way that we
all connect um
uh
so yeah i do think that there's maybe an
over-reliance on that as being part of a
club
um but i think that there's so many
different ways to connect with people
whether it's you know a shared passion
for
food or film or
you know um
maybe a place
like
uh you know the chug and monkey bar in
austin texas on sixth street i don't
know why that popped into my head but i
love that bar um
so
like
you know i just because i am a person
that loves to connect with people like
i'll find some way i do think maybe
there is an over reliance on the alma
mater being the thing um i tend to
connect with people the easiest way to
connect is through a passion for film
and all types of film i really am i do
think it's important that we have
a balanced media diet
oh what is that a balanced media diet is
absolutely critical
in the same way that what we put into
our bodies is just as important if you
lived only on fast food say hollywood
blockbuster movies
i find that um
first of all if you only ate mcdonald's
there's already been a movie made about
that and it doesn't do good things to
your body right like fast food greasy
food not good for you
balance
and i feel like
we don't pay enough attention to our
media diet and the media diet has to be
yes fine i'm gonna go see that marvel
movie right
i'm gonna go see that movie that a lot
of movie these days they're just like
theme park rides they're not movies
right they're selling products and i'm
going to balance that out by seeing a
really amazing documentary or a small
independent film made by a filmmaker
i've never heard of put out like by a
gravitas ventures or something or a 1091
or 824 one of these other companies well
824 is warner brothers that's another
story but the orchard the orchard yeah
a24 is very good taste if you ask oh
they do i i really do love their the
their how they curate the films that
they put out or an ifc participant yeah
yeah like like
have a balanced media diet if you
there's a whole group of youtubers
that are on that that have made a living
on giant franchises and i say
i agree with first of all i agree with
many of them those franchises are
terrible the modern incarnations of some
of these franchises that have been
around more than 20 years
they've sort of run it into the ground
um but i feel like maybe you wouldn't be
as
upset about them if you had a balanced
media diet meaning
meaning yeah i'll see the latest
whatever forgettable big blockbuster
movie but because i have seen some
smaller film this is a weird example
psycho gourmand
um
you know or um a movie a documentary i
would highly recommend called clapboard
jungle which is about um
it's about a filmmaker's journey
uh trying to you know
actually find a way to make
money in this in crazy industry i think
you need to have a balanced media diet
and that's
at least what my mission is with film
thread is we tend to champion filmmakers
who make these smaller movies
because there are
plenty of other websites that cover star
wars marvel pixar disney
right
um those are all one company if i right
marvel pixar star wars disney that's all
one company putting out the stuff it
really is a monopoly it's
unfortunate that these big blockbusters
have that um but
but
those are okay to see
but you should not only see those it's
just like you know within like see one
of those and then see a smaller film see
one of those see a documentary see one
of those see another documentary like
break it up and really look like whether
it's like you're scrolling through
itunes or voodoo or whatever one of
those services where you can purchase or
rent movies and look at the you know
video on demand stuff that's just come
out you're gonna find some incredible
stuff
and and that's where i feel very
fortunate and that's part of our mission
um
is to say look at these movies because
if you only lived off the
giant franchise films you will find only
disappointment
and so and so break it up a bit maybe
you won't be as upset about that so
um
have a balanced media diet so there's
four food groups right and there's four
like you know you have your blockbusters
you have your documentaries you have
your art house and then maybe something
with subtitles
sure okay
i actually you know what i will say this
i put subtitles on when i don't have to
because you learned so much when i
watched game of thrones i knew all the
characters names because i watched it
with with the closed captioning on
uh it's great it's it's really it's
really fantastic so i i actually
recommend closed captioning even if it's
a film that's in your the the language
that you're familiar with your native
language is it's uh you you
you'll you'll learn more um because
especially because a lot of it is like
you'll get some of the direction that's
directly out of the screenplay right
like like it's really useful and
thinking like a writer i think that
watching a movie with closed captioning
on in english even if you are an english
speaker
is really useful uh
so i tend to do that
i don't know is that i don't know if
that's a thing i do it uh
i think i have friends who think i'm
crazy for doing it i find it incredibly
um
you'll learn a lot more about what
you're watching
i know my limits i know what i'm good at
and i'm not you know and i tend to go
towards my strengths and and when i did
stand up i don't think that that was
while i'm comfortable being in front of
an audience
um when i saw the guys that were really
good at it
i was like oh
the amount of effort like
it just was not for me and then and then
additionally
um hecklers too well it's not the
heckler so much that i didn't mind
hecklers or people in the audience that
that the crowd work is fun to me um i
love crowd work mainly because i like
people more than anything i love
you know i just love people uh
i have now become my grandmother where i
have conversations with people in
grocery lines oh yeah yeah that's that's
i've become that guy uh but but um are
you the ones having the conversation
sorry to interrupt with the demo people
the demo people you know when they do
the free samples oh no you know you've
really crossed over when you have five
hours
no but i'll like i don't know i just
i you know um i feel like it's like
getting out of our social media bubble i
think you if you only read social media
and especially twitter which i think is
horrible horribly toxic and not a
representation of real life
um
i
i think if you just go outside and talk
to people all of the the vitriol um it's
not there people face to face
speaking face to face
um
you know there there there's more that's
communicated you know
by looking in someone's eyes and i think
i think um i think unfortunately social
media has has brought out
so many demons i mean maybe maybe it's a
good thing in the sense that those
demons are online and then they don't
exist in the real world as much but um
we're living in some really bizarre
times if
you know i don't i think that's an
understatement
um
yes now see i'm the one going off on
tangents
you